thank you all so much how's it going
how we doing ted ted women
they brought me in for a bit of comic
relief
i'm so excited to be here at ted women
you know i i think i speak for myself
but also for all of us
when i think i'm really inspired you
know and personally i feel like i'm not
going to stop
until every person living or dead is a
woman
and yeah
yeah i think that's where we're at
no but i do hate when people say that
god is a woman
right i hate that i really i think she
would have done better you know
no
yeah
it's like if god is a woman she's a real
guy's gal if you know what i mean
so
i'm gonna do a couple songs for you guys
um so this first one i wrote before
lockdown but it became especially
relevant and it's about this thing i do
um where i like somebody i have a crush
or maybe we go on a couple dates
and instead of letting things unfold
naturally
i'll sort of accidentally scroll their
instagram back until 2012.
this song's about that
i learned too much about you too soon
because i couldn't wait
yes i
interned stalked you
to the point that we can no longer die
cause i know your mother's name and your
father's name and your sister's name and
your cousin's husband's name
i know that your uncle recently passed
away
and i'm so sorry about that babe
i know every girl that you've ever dated
and the exact day you stopped being
happy
your posture changed
i know that you and your friends hike
a lot
it's
too much we'll change that i've seen
every photo tagged of you on the entire
internet
i know you dropped out of college but
your spanish it's polished and you own
approximately five shirts
the police are outside my door
but i'm clutching your head all i made
on the
floor
if they ever tell people how often other
people look at their profiles i will
kill myself
so goodbye
i love where i
start
thank you
it's vulnerable
i feel like it's like a thing people say
when conversation gets kind of boring at
parties you know or they're like did you
hear there's an app where you can see
who looks at your instagrams like that's
not funny
it's not funny it's not a cool thing to
say
i feel like there are people here have
been married for 40 years they're like
what the hell is she talking about
yeah it's complicated now it's gotten
complicated
no i know
you don't have to be old to be married
40 years some people get married and
they're like 20.
not me um
i do i do understand why like baby
boomers are sort of afraid now that
millennials are getting older you know
now that we're getting real jobs i do
get that you know it's hard to imagine a
millennial in a serious job right can
you imagine a millennial as a doctor
you know
like not to be a [ __ ] but you have
cancer
[Applause]
you know
like hands your prognosis like i'm
really sorry actually i'm not sorry
i'll tell you a little about myself
i had a pretty crazy last couple of
years so basically i had this set come
out for comedy central short set came
out april 2020 so right when we had just
gotten into lock town
and then cut to like six months later
one of the songs i did from that set
went super viral on tick tock
and right i was not on tick-tock okay
because i'm 32. so i sort of didn't know
we were allowed
but we are
and it was crazy because there's all
these people lip-syncing my song but in
my real life i had just started this job
working customer support for a food
delivery app so answering phone calls
for customer support the worst job i've
ever had in my life
so it was this really weird
juxtaposition because i'm having this
huge career moment when i look at my
phone right people are tweeting at me
like we love you
you're a genius and then for eight hours
a day people like you're a [ __ ] where's
my food
[Laughter]
and it was really interesting to
experience
so i'm gonna play the song for you guys
and then i'm gonna go over some of my
favorite male reactions that i got on
the internet afterwards
so
this song maybe you've heard it maybe
haven't it is um the true story about
the first american woman who they ever
sent to space whose name was sally ride
remember when nasa sent a woman to space
for only six days and they gave her
100 tampons
100 tampons
[Applause]
and they asked will that be enough
[Applause]
cause they didn't know if that was
enough
these are our nation's greatest minds
they are literally rocket scientists
they also tied the tampons together
by the strings like sausages
100 tampons
a hundred tampons
i can picture it now
come with me
i'm sally right and i'm going to space
for the first time i'm walking tall
i feel so proud
then i see a man running panic through
the crowd
he's holding a large bag
[Music]
i think what can this be
and then he hands 100 tampons to me
and then he hands 100 tampons to me for
one week
they could have asked me
[Music]
i would have said maybe 33.
cause even if it were my period week
i might have already brought some with
me
[Music]
but you know
thanks i guess
[Music]
100 tampons how does she use a tampon
when they tied the strings together
100
tampons don't hate me
525
600 tampons so sorry 525
000
[Music]
in space
thank you all
thank you so much thank you
thank you i really appreciate it
so
men on the internet were furious about
this song
furious and it's funny because honestly
to be honest out of all the feminist
comedy songs that i've written this is
the absolute tamest by far
like for example me and my bandmate
isabel martin we wrote a song called all
older white men should die parentheses
but not my dad
so i really didn't think this would make
them that angry
i really didn't
but they were enraged so i wanted to
show you some of my favorite genres
of comments that i got
so this first one we have what i call
the honest critic just offering a
critique
okay so so he starts
it was funny at first but then she
ruined it okay all right let's hear him
out someone said
please elaborate
all right you have criticism let's hear
it
she kept yapping about the tampons yeah
and you know what fair
so you know i'm gonna take the i mean to
be honest the tampons is sort of a
central part of the song
but i'll take the note you know
we'll work it going forward
this next one i call the microgravity
expert and this this was an absolutely
amazing phenomenon because what happened
was
somehow within the three to four minutes
of my song
thousands of men on the internet became
experts in microgravity
and menstruation
and i think that is so impressive
because normally that sort of takes
years
to really understand
but they got it like that and i just
think
that is huge he said at that time nobody
had experience having a period of
microgravity relax
because really that's what they're angry
about is they're sitting at their
computer like stop laughing
it isn't funny
this next comment this pissed me off
more than anything this type of comment
i'll just show you
look at beau barnum up if you liked and
then the person said i did look him up
and he's really good thanks for the
suggestion
guys can we focus on me can we please
focus on me
okay bo burnham has had three netflix
specials all right i just quit my job at
customer support okay so let's ice let's
just focus on me okay it's my song okay
thank you
so thank you so much this last one um
this is what i called the essayist and
this is somebody who i'm sure they were
pitching to the new york times and new
york times said we're full this month so
they decided to just dm it to me
directly and i think that's great
um this went on for several paragraphs i
will say
uh does 100 tampons really seem that
unreasonable considering that it's nasa
huh
i'm male no
i really i thought this message was a
woman that's wow
and i understand that you wouldn't take
100 with you on a seven day vacation but
nasa had to plan for the absolute worst
case scenario
from a quick google
i see most women use 3 to 10 tampons per
day
10 being an absolute disaster of a
flow an absolute disaster
of a flow because this is what their
fear was wasn't it the men in nassau
they're like she's gonna get up there
it's gonna come out of her eyes and her
ears and her mouth
and if we don't have 100 tampons boys
we're in trouble
we're in real trouble up there boys
so i wrote him back i said you're
absolutely right i'll cut the song i'll
delete it right now it doesn't make any
sense you're completely right
but
in all honesty i am really really
thankful if this song started any
conversation where it might otherwise be
uncomfortable about periods that's a lot
of the feedback i got and that was the
most amazing thing to me like people
sending it in their slack channels to
their bosses texting it to their dads
and i just think it's really insane as
we all know that half the population
bleeds and the other half has no idea
what is going on and
i'm really grateful for that and i know
it sounds cheesy but i often just find
myself thinking that i really hope sally
would have liked it so thank you all so
much thank you